[Music]
tell me something
you can go anywhere
[Music]
another timeline
Another Universe
so why do you want to stay
fight to save this one
this is the world where my mom lives I'm
not gonna lose her again
[Music]
time has a pattern
can't help reliving
different people different worlds
drawn to each other with magnets
[Music]
my face so my face
if you were to go into the past
you have no idea what the consequences
can be Bruce I could fix things you
could also destroy everything
is happening
completely broke the universe
outside we've been waiting for you
I created a world with no metahumans
and now there's no one to defend us
want some help
oh you're
you're you are yeah
I'm Batman
[Music]
if I can't undo what I did
if I can't get back
there might not be a future
what's the plate Batman what do we do we
try not to die
it's not quark
my name is Kara Barry
Barry what are you doing our kids are
gonna want to see this
[Music]
thank you